No okay there's that
oh I haven't talked out loud for a
little bit hi my name is Chris Helbig
if you didn't know now you know your
life is different now I took a little
bit of a hey ATIS and now I'm gonna come
back and make some videos some stuff I
want to talk about a little bit I have
short hair it's all mine and all is
completely rooted into my head and
doesn't belong to mysterious strangers
that I purchased and then taped into my
skull so that's very cool took a little
bit of a break in I decided sorta that I
wanted to come back and come back
there's no I took like a month and a
half off there's took some time away and
here some personal stuff going on now I
have slowly started to get into the mode
of missing making YouTube videos I was
in a pattern where I felt like I had to
rather than I wanted to and I'm slowly
starting to get back into the want
instead of have to which is obviously
the best way to make anything is because
you want to not because you have to I'm
in a hotel room in Austin Texas and it
just felt appropriate to be doing a
video from a hotel room because that's
what I used to do without worry about it
being good or measure up to like a
standard how to use a hotel room it
doesn't really make sure there's a place
I can do hot yoga I can't go a day
without my hat yeah oh god this thing
Wow - swimming one more foot just doing
like ah secondly Kentucky Derby
a lot of what started to make me very
anxious and sad and scared and nervous
about making YouTube videos was this
idea that I had to like level up and you
guys know me for maybe some of you for
like 10 plus years which hey happy
decade of knowing each other weird I
guess I just like starting to get really
anxious about the idea that I had to
start to figure out better way to make
videos it had to be higher quality it
had to be bigger concepts and to be a
bigger production team it had to be all
of these things that just weren't like
true to me because I wasn't doing that I
just sort of like mmm
did that caved in on myself and avoided
all of that and then just look was a
constant cyclical thing of feeling bad
about having some arbitrary standard
that I had to like meet which isn't a
true or real thing turns out also the
other thing that I want to talk about in
taking breaks I think the idea of taking
a break especially for youtubers right
now because the whole YouTube and
digital industry is brand-new we have
not seen the same way that we've seen in
traditional media the tropes have like
child actors going nuts and like people
like losing their brain like and
paparazzi I'm like this swarm we haven't
seen that in YouTube space we're only
learning about it as it goes and it
feels like there's a lot of stress on
mental health right now for a lot of
youtubers which i think is absolutely
wonderful doing this is really stressful
especially for a lot of us that started
when this wasn't this movie started when
this was just fun and now this is a
really stressful sometimes thing to do
so there is a whole healthcare mental
health side of it and I think we're kind
of at the threshold of that being
something that we start talking about
hopefully authentically I hate when
people take advantage of talking about
mental health oh there's my ghost light
that keeps going on I took a break and I
think people romanticize this idea of
like she's in do her eat pray
moment no I took a break and I asked
there's some things I'm definitely proud
of but there's others where I'm like I'm
just doing this because I think I have
to on this platform you coming in like a
wrecking ball sack girl have more than
two selfies I'm done I'm just kind of
getting my vibe that you take a lot of
pictures of yourself the music so
dramatic
some Bad's gonna happen Kim's gonna go
give Tristen a talking-to I got sad and
again and then got more sad my
acceptance of my break was when I
realized that a a break doesn't mean
you're gonna fix stuff when you take a
break it does not mean that within a
certain period of time you were gonna
get everything sorted out no I still go
crazy
I still feel stressed out I still feel
anxious I still feel nervous I still
feel you know insecure about a lot of
this stuff but I've come to terms with
the idea that there's not gonna be that
magical you Pray Love ish epiphany
moment that's gonna fix everything and
give me full clarity on like the way to
direct the future content that I try to
create am I breaking out in hives
probably I get nervous talking about all
of it the biggest epiphany of I've had
is that I can't just sit around and wait
for the universe to like fix me or
present a better situation for me or
change my mental state or help me cope
in certain ways I have to do it myself
and I also have to accept that it you
know it's not a beautiful Hollywood
movie moment I'm gonna feel anxious but
the thing I miss is like this and I
I admit I'd miss giving myself
permission to be stupid with you guys I
think I started to get really insecure
about being stupid just such a weird
sentiment to say but I I did I wouldn't
let myself be silly
with you guys because behind the scenes
that wasn't feeling very silly I think
this is a grossest 33 yeah
start making YouTube videos when I was
in college I don't think I've given
myself permission to be an adult I do
you guys so that's another part of it I
don't know what this is I miss you guys
I miss making videos I don't want to
start making them more I don't know what
I'm gonna do I shot a collab with Tyler
that I'm really excited about and that
really kind of kick-started me being
like I missed this man I had this really
great quote in her Forbes the interview
if you haven't read it you should really
really read it it's really wonderful
where she just says that she's not
trying to be the number one youtuber
she's just trying to like enjoy what she
does and that really really resonated
with me
and I think that's what I need to allow
myself to my ghost is back hey girl
I did allow myself to feel comfortable
being a little bit different than I used
to be with you guys and then see where
they go just free-falling into this like
33 year-old grace Helbig self and then
see what happens I also tried to film
this video many times before but I was
too drunk and I know like a lot of
youtubers go I tried to film this video
like seven times
you know I have the receipts I tried to
film this video there's no right or
wrong way to self well there's a wrong
way to self care for that baby
everything you see is real I can't even
bring myself to make a click bite title
like I the title of this video is
probably something so [ __ ] pure and
totally saccharine that I I can't bring
myself to do what they do because I
don't want to make you guys think that
that's ok I don't even know this time is
more coherent than the others but that
said I thank you guys if you're new
welcome and if you're not new thank you
for being here let's grow together that
sounded a little pervy but kind of
aspirational I don't know
there we go what are you doing yeah okay